foreign
this machine is the seated route to
adjust the seat you pull the yellow
lever up to where you require the seat
to be you then change the range of
movement by pulling the yellow pin up
and pulling the pad towards you or away
you want to only just be able to reach
the handles to change the weight you
pull the yellow pin out and place it in
the weight selected you can also push
the 2.5 increment in to add more weight
to then begin the movement you want to
keep the chest securely on the pad in
front and head straight on
you want to pull the elbows back just
past the back and squeezing the shoulder
blades together
avoid moving the chest away from the pad
[Music]
make sure that on the relaxing phase you
aren't rushing it
[Music]